michael king has really kind of
worked his way up the ladder on the
prospect rankings over the last couple
of years and under three era in his
career in the minor leagues and he
really does deserve this shot nemo is
ready king
is ready swing and a miss he powered it
by him
and nimo down on strikes movement and
life on that fastball
gary set up in but you can see it kind
of running up and away but
sometimes when you've got just natural
life on your pitches
they work today they face rick porcela
whom they have faced
a lot and they're not very pretty and
you notice the walks
he doesn't walk anybody does not give up
home runs it's the 40 hits that have
been
the bugaboo for him can that'll bring up
luke voight
[Applause]
line drive off the glove of davis and it
trickles into left field
lemay who's rounding second he's going
to go to third he'll make it
there's nobody at second base so boyd
gets in there as well
jd davis has had a really good series
defensively just just off the end of the
glove
big break for the yankees there's the
3-2 coming to hicks
with three and two and he catches the
inside corner strike three called
that come back to seymour to get hicks
looking for the first down
that's a strike and that's a good one
now mike tuchman a left-hand hitter
coming up and he's been called
one for his last 12.
up the middle that'll get a run in
jimenez fields and fires
to alonso so lemay who scores voigt
moves
to third talkman picks up a ribby and
it's one nothing inks
getting the job done i mean you cannot
get a lead off
walk and then a double and come up
empty-handed so at least the yankees on
the board
dom smith the cleanup hitter leads off
dom hits one out toward the gap in right
center field headed back toward the wall
and it hops up
against the fence smith heads for second
as hicks plays it in
and dom smith does a lead off double in
the second inning his 19th extra base
hit of the season
12 doubles and seven home runs and 82 at
bats he is having a
phenomenal season unbelievable
demo struck out his first time up runner
goes
swung on it missed and he stopped on a
dime and headed back to first so
nimo strikes out x stays at first
kind of king's ghost go-to location
against left-handed batters and it
served them well right there
tyler wade leads off for the yankees as
we hit the bottom of the third
line drive base it for wade
so he starts the third with a single
this is what the
yankees are waiting for to see him get
on base regularly
and use that speed nice line drive swing
to right field
and that brings up lemayo sixth pitch of
this at bat
and he hits a double play ball waiting
on at mcneal jimenez with the turn
in time for the 4-6-3 double play so
porcello doing what he does best getting
ground balls
and the mets able to turn the two now
luke voigt the batter he could be a
one-man rally
no doubt about that and porcello strikes
him out with the slider
so porcello has his second strikeout of
the day as he gets voight
one-nothing yankees after three and the
mets have the tying run at third
runners at the corners with one out so a
chance for pete alonso to get
the tying run home and pete breaks his
back lines it into center field for a
base hit
that'll bring in davis with the tying
run a broken back
rbi single for pete alonso and the mets
have drawn even at one
and they give pete credit there for
going down and getting it wilson ramos
who has
spectacular career numbers with the
bases loaded 1-1 to ramos
he lines one the other way base hit and
the mets take the lead canoe is in
they'll stop alonso in third
the fifth hit of the inning wilson ramos
goes the other way for an rbi
single and it's two to one mets well
done just got it by ford it was playing
wide of the bag at first
26 year old out of southern cal comes in
to face brandon nemo with the bases
loaded and two out
the 02. oh what a good job by crisky
three pitches he strikes out nimmo
and the mets leave the bases loaded but
they do take a two to one lead
as we head to the bottom of the fourth
mike ford will be the batter grounded
into the shift his last time runner goes
lofted into left field and deep smith
turned the wrong way turns the runway
again
and it's over is headed up against the
wall talkman runs third he will score
it's an rbi double for ford and it's a
2-2 game
absolutely lost it by talkman being in
motion
easily scores but this is a bad position
to be in
when you're turning one way and the ball
is going to the other
canoe is one for two and a base hit and
scored a run in the fourth
and he drives one out to right field
talkman goes back
and it's out of here robinson canoe
gives the mets the lead with a two-run
homer
career hit number 2600 for robinson
canoe
his fifth home run of the year and the
mets laid it 4-2
spaces loaded nobody out michael
conforto looking to break this game open
29 year old ben heller delivers and it's
lined the other way that's a base set
for conforto
it'll go into the corner ramos is in
jimenez scores
heading for third nimmo he'll be held
there it's a two-run double from michael
conforto
and the mets stretch their lead to six
to two
so now two out of the bases loaded for
alonso who has an rbi single in three
trips in this game
and that hit him that's gonna force in a
run
pete gets clipped by the pitch nimmo
comes in to score
and it's seven to two minutes just like
that the he's have the bases loaded
for luke voight check swing it's gonna
be a base hit
two runs will score estrada goes to
third and he almost got thrown out
wow two run single for voight and that
brings up hicks is the tying run
2-2 inside it gets away
did it hit him it goes to the backstop
ramos didn't run after it
a run comes in and now it's seven to
five
boy on second base yankees down by two
drilled to right field did he get it
high enough
yes he did oh my the yankees have come
all the way back
to tie the game at seven a clutch
two-run home run
for aaron hicks and we've got a ball
game
and there's geo or shella and the pitch
lined into right field here comes
comforto he's gonna go playing on the
hop
here here's the throw tuckman is
safe and the yankees win eight to seven
or seven with the base hit they've come
all the way back
and they take an unlikely victory in the
first game of a doubleheader